staff first being totally unrealistic
each is fired nuclear weapon from a
shoulder
[Music]
I'm Marvel Billingham I spent 27 years
in the military nine the parity of
regiment seventeen to plus years with
the SAS since leaving the Armed Forces I
then became head of security for a
number of a lists including Angelina
Jolie and Brad Pitt and now I'm
currently now working in the TV industry
as an advisor on SES who Jasmine's the
equipment and the little birds were the
early copters he's probably quite right
that's exactly how you're riding into
battle they these do flying down the
streets the way we see that he's
probably a bit unrealistic bearing in
mind in astana environment now don't get
me wrong these things can fly under
washing lights are unbelievable but I
just find out a little bit unrealistic
I'm guessing because of the timelines
they have to move in daylight ok the
second phase I'm looking at now they're
coming in in the Black Hawks and
delivering the troops by what we call
fast Rob wishes a rose from the side of
the aircraft the unreal is again in my
eyes is that dropping right onto the
target broad daylight and if you
basically sitting duck
as for rolling out for in front of a 50
cattle weapon laughing that's a little
bit OTT the grenade launcher from these
small arms weapon there he's totally
overkill what it would do is
fragmentation a little bit of a noise
it's certainly one burst into flame okay
so the first incident you see there is
what they call a coach option where you
know about to storm a coach for whatever
reason believing is terrorist on it now
the drills and skills and the equipment
back of the day he's actually very
correct pretty spawn
what we call rehearsals and what the
rear scenaries close quarter battle
clearing a building a strong old where
ostriches may be held the drills and
skills again exactly as this is a very
sort of light roll they'll do this five
or six times this is a walk through tour
proved then I'll do it a little bit
faster and then eventually they do in
fall equipment so what I'm seeing there
he's actually pretty accurate
the effects of a grenade is exactly that
it's the only thing missing was probably
the noise there's a little bit more
noise to it but there's no big balls of
fire there's no walls falling in and
falling down as exactly as it is
it's an Arnie movie the way he's dressed
is just ridiculous it's all about
looking my image as a person what I'm
trying to do he's got weapons and guns
all over him
each is fired nuclear weapon from a
shoulder it's just ridiculous you know
I've never even seen that sort of rocket
launcher anyway and the other thing is
even if the enemy I'm running along and
firing from down here from the hip for
some strange reason and running in front
of each other but no one seems to be
shooting it's just ridiculous you know
he stood behind a cup of leaves and no
one can hit him well one of those
nuclear grenades again not seem to just
destroy everything in in a 50-mile
radius totally unrealistic
of course you're afraid okay my biggest
criticism there is your own operations
you're already in you know in the enemy
territory behind the lines and your
weapons should already be done it's in
ready to go but not caught only out open
then it's a bad use of ground they
should have been in cover
what the anti-tank weapons could do that
they've just fired into 66 again totally
unrealistic unless it's a fuel Bowser in
wouldn't burst into flames so it that's
just what effects
he is those are our guys can you confirm
its him
it's him oh it's it Ryan
he's your [ __ ] you know people do long
distance shots and to say that's over a
mile and being able to confirm firstly
that's the target because of the
distance not my own car the science are
and also it's a desert terrain you'd
normally get the heat rising so there'd
be some sort of distraction between if
it's not the heat from the naturally
coming off the ground and out there it's
eat from the buildings it may be a
miracle day where it was totally calm
and there's no eat rice which I find
I've never known it knowing it I've been
being a sniper you can see it's a target
I'll give him that and you know it's
worth a shot
don't go down you may have seen him fall
that doesn't mean he's been hit doesn't
mean he's dead
so there the questionable things I would
say but however an amazing job and
amazing things can do is sole job is to
protect that principle so reality rather
than curling up in his own seed I would
have crawled into the back and got hold
of her because you don't want she gonna
do she's gonna panics you're gonna raise
her head into the glass it really should
have reacted better by being on top of
her getting her down low in the wheel
well and protecting her
[ __ ] whistle kids even roof of passport
house 1 zebras even if it got her out of
the vehicle get it down with it and get
him moving he's now starting to you know
time take control of the vehicle when
shooting them from the start to be
honest but again realistically Zoli said
there's one sniper which are we
identified was a bit unrealistic it
should have just took it up a side
street you can't see everywhere coming
from any sniper position so right now
the biggest problem with this if you had
a bodyguard what his primary role is to
look after the principal he's now left
there unattended all on wrong to go and
be a near-daily took himself out of the
vehicle leaving her vulnerable then he's
now left the vehicle to become a Nero
where is she she's on her own
told they're not doing that bodyguard
job
okay that's a view initially from the
operations room as an operation is
taking place which again these pretty
realistic in terms of the atmosphere
inside the operation room when it's
going down
everyone's watching all the radars watch
the TVs listen to the communications and
everybody's got the heart in the mouth
and not really saying a lot put a little
bit more detail and I never actually see
myself but it's it's pretty realistic
the the wareness shades he's very much a
Nollywood thing that doesn't happen so
you moving through shade you lose all
perspective alright so that's the only
fault I see with the equipment and
movement from the start what they were
actually doing again is not unrealistic
guys in terms of tasks that the military
would do it would do be done a lot more
covertly it was a little bit loud they
would not come down for whatever reason
which I find a little bit on realistic
is the bunching up where they all just
come together knowing full well that
they're being shot up the big drill is
to stay away from each other because the
more together they're bigger the target
where the rocket-propelled grenade the
rpg-7 landed and all of a sudden
everybody's catapulted in the air
totally unrealistic what it actually
does it would blow you off your feet to
a degree but you'll be covered in
shrapnel and probably on body parts
missing so it's a little bit Hollywood
iced with the rolling down the hill and
all the rest of the stuff alright the
weapon is not a massive priority really
if it was a person left behind yes the
bidding contact the money to break
contact by falling back and now the
reason again they've really good the
position away again by talking too loud
and not moving and getting the hell out
of it
stop flying through the air hanging off
the bottom of an anechoic no that does
not happen okay some of the explosive
entry drills the window charge is pretty
realistic the door
shotgun drills on the door again
realistic well since this granese being
thrown around in there most of this is
stun grenades as opposed to
fragmentation grenades the equipment of
wearing from what I can see again it's
pretty realistic the synchronized I'm
sailing down the wall is a little bit
dramatic he takes a while to set up and
I'm saying and do all that sort of stuff
you just won't have time to be able to
do it's not like you see in spider where
you can just attach it and go but it
gets into position and then once so he
goes noisy then you go it's not
[Music]
the people get hung up on churches and
treat yes it did you know when they
jumped into and around villages you got
blown all over the place or your drops
in the wrong place so that can happen
the way that probably happened is a
little bit sort of again unrealistic
you know you come there with one eye
love a smash and you probably get badly
injured as opposed to bounce around like
you're on a bouncy castle
he still got his reserve parachute
attached to him and the way to get down
is to pull that parachute because I'll
then I'll drop down to the ground on
attacks one side and climbed down it and
whatever reason he decides to watch the
show going on below in for a while and
then decides oh maybe I should get out
and then starts cutting himself away so
there's bullets and bombs going off all
around it but the Germans still earn the
knife or which is a bit weird
the chaos of it all the the ridiculous
sort of obstacles to come up against
which is not just bullets and bombs the
water get off a boat so it's I think
this is portrayed really really well and
haven't seen that sort of the tracer
lines of the rounds going through the
water although I've not been shot at
underwater I've seen the effects of fire
through water now in my eyes and my
opinion is pretty realistic
I'm simply was shot in the [ __ ] war I
mean it goes off at a tangent but if you
let you firing a bunch of people you
find randomly it's quite lightly that's
something somebody's gonna get hit you
know it's the same as just firing into a
crowd it's indiscriminate the realism of
you know the sounds of bullets gone past
you but that's shown really really well
the chaoticness I've gone what's going
around you're not just about you being
quieter when I do find I'm watching
anything military orientated I do tend
to be a little bit critical about the
scenes if I had to say at a favorite
movie that is military based I would say
it's aren't great rich purely because of
the influence of Clint Eastwood and then
obviously it's based on the real story
to a little bit dramatize but it's
actually quite good movie in my eyes
[Music]